[Music]
we welcome you back to cbs this morning
only on ctm we're hearing from the first
woman to be named
a four-star coast guard admiral
it is her first network tv interview
since taking the job admiral linda fagan
has worn the uniform
for 40 years she served everywhere from
glaciers of antarctica to tokyo
and new york harbor with a lot of other
ports along the way
our catherine herridge spent some time
with her on the water and she joins us
now from along the potomac river near
washington catherine good morning
david after 9 11 the coast guard was
moved into the department of homeland
security where it has a broad domestic
and international portfolio the need has
never been greater at a time the force
is undergoing profound change
when you first set foot on a boat like
this did you imagine
you would become the vice commander in
the number two position at the coast
guard
absolutely not and melinda fagan's
journey to a position
overseeing some 40 thousand coast
guardsmen
has taken her to all seven continents
homeland security is not a home game
there's an away game component to it and
we operate in both the home game
and the away game cruising past the
potomac's iconic shoreline
earlier this summer fagin described a
mission that combines policing with the
might
of a military service it is about
presence
and law enforcement much more than
uh you know lethality like our navy
counterparts talk about
while addressing the needs of an
evolving force
i look at some of the policy changes
that are helping us retain women
the focus on diversity and inclusion so
that we better
represent the public that we serve
before getting on the water
we're going to go to the left cbs news
spent the morning with the admiral at
coast guard headquarters
with rare access to the daily operations
brief
gusts up to 130 miles per hour okay we
always start with the weather we're see
going service
in the ceremonial hall we sat down for
the admiral's
first network tv interview since
starting the job
in june what's the biggest misconception
we are globally deployed i think that
that is probably a misconception
well you're the coast guard shouldn't
you just be along the coast
that includes responding to migrants
fleeing the ongoing crises in both
cuba and haiti there are 20 people that
we know
have lost their lives in the last month
in those attempts
high-risk missions intercepting drugs
it's life-saving work these are
narcotics that don't reach the
shores of the u.s and then result in
drug overdoses
and ensuring safe passage for global
trade
your concern is a cyber attack and and
the ripple effect on
the supply chain absolutely yes yeah
disruption of the supply chain in a way
that then begins to
you know impact our just way of life
everyday consumers
everyday consumers yep as i said it's uh
the nikes get here
they get here on a ship in a container
at 18
fagin enrolled at the coast guard
academy
just a few years after service academy
doors were open to women
after graduation fagin nearly got bumped
from her first tour
at the time the executive officer when i
did my inbrief
uh was like actually we we thought about
canceling your orders
we didn't want only one woman on board
and thankfully they did not and it was
an incredible
first tour for me really impactful for
everything that came after that
three minutes women now make up 15
percent
and minorities roughly 30 percent of the
coast guard's active duty force
but at the admiral's morning briefing we
noticed she was still
the only woman at the table so we've
made a lot of progress in the junior
ranks
we need to keep making progress we do
not yet reflect the society who we serve
and
we need to we need to keep working on
that with a daughter serving in the
coast guard it's personal for fagin
who says assistance with things like
relocation and daycare
are making a difference for this
generation as
particularly women face you know career
and family choices that we make it
easier for them to envision themselves
so
still serving with this incredible
organization as our tour concludes
fagin reflected on the gravity of her
mission
you know i've taken an oath to protect
and defend the constitution
and charting the course for the next
generation i recognize
i am now providing a set of shoulders
for those who will come
after admiral fagan is just the third
woman to be vice commandant of the coast
guard fagan said their service
has paved the way for hers and now it's
her turn to pay it forward anthony
congratulations to the admiral catherine
thank you and but still the only
woman at the table as you point out
we'll be right back